we have breaking news tonight on the
investigation into why the just removed
number-two man at the FBI did not act on
a request to examine some of Hillary
Clinton's emails during several crucial
weeks before the 2016 election chief
intelligence correspondent Catherine
Herridge is here to tell us what she's
hearing good evening Catherine well
thank you bright tonight The Washington
Post reports and Fox News is working to
confirm independently the Justice
Department's internal watchdog has been
investigating why a critical chapter in
the criminal email probe three weeks
before the presidential election seemed
to stall once it reached then Deputy
Director Andrew McCabe federal law
enforcement sources have complained to
Fox News that FBI headquarters appeared
to slow roll a review of classified
Clinton emails found on the laptop
shared by Anthony Weiner and is then a
strange wife Clinton campaign aide Huma
Abedin central line of questioning is
reportedly focused on whether McCabe or
anyone else at the bureau wanted to
avoid taking action on the newly
recovered laptop emails until after the
election no action was taken until late
October when the case was briefly
reopened after meeting with FBI director
Christopher ray on Monday about the
Inspector General's investigation McCabe
was removed and placed on terminal leave
Brett Catherine where are we on the
release of that Intel memo
well there's conflicting reporting
tonight on the timing but the consensus
is sooner rather than later
we need to have transparency and
accountability the public release of the
Republican staff memo documenting
alleged surveillance abuses divided
along party lines we across the Rubicon
we are doing something that keeps us
less safe for purely political reasons
after the removal of FBI deputy director
Andrew McCabe now the sixth FBI
executive to retire be fired reassigned
or demoted at his weekly news conference
the House Speaker put the emphasis on
Bureau senior leadership not the
rank-and-file agents there may have been
malfeasance at the FBI by certain
individuals after Monday's contentious
vote behind closed doors many staffers
physically took the memo to the White
House a source familiar with the
discussions tells Fox that President
Trump told aides he wants the memo out
as soon as possible but not before State
of the Union the committee senior
Democrat warned of national security
implications there was a vote to
politicize the declassification process
of intelligence and potentially
compromised
sources and methods but a source told
Fox the memo was drafted to deliberately
eliminate national security information
in a recent interview the Oversight
Committee Chairman said great care was
taken there's a way to communicate what
I think we need to communicate to the
American people without jeopardizing
sources and methods after FBI director
ray reviewed the surveillance memo on
Capitol Hill Sunday to senior FBI
officials one from the bureau's
counterintelligence division the other
from legal followed up a source familiar
with the matter said they could not
point to any factual inaccuracies while
the FBI had no comment a Justice
Department official disputed the
characterization Democrats have seized
on this January 24th Justice Department
letter calling the memos release
unprecedented and reckless but after
their own review at main justice an
official from the Justice Department
told Fox the term reckless is now moot
House Intelligence Committee is working
to schedule the remaining Russia
investigation interviews with the FBI
Justice Department and we're told the
target is early to mid February Brett
Catherine thank you